he remains Solomon locket al-arabiya to
Saudi tamil disha for a free upon Tamela
of akhaten in metallic teri finish will
30th be mafia I can
blah melisma freaking Sawadee Laura
McClatchy yeah dull mood for Philip
Gingrich in JAMA at Ann Arbor FEMA
chicken lamb use of the coup mother Haza
home hiatus Philemon Zubat artisan in he
has a juicy minister Atiyah allaha free
yet and he ten most origin and has in
Montego cana-deuce and mineral bar
colossal Satori what we found
working for Wales was something
completely different
kudamon awful mantras Ohio on a web site
at ELISA her to zero GS idea
for evoke an emotional memorial noon Lee
had salmet yard had gone off to Saudi
Arabia and we said when you're out there
look in the tertiary deposits see what
you can find and you could walk over
that fossil a hundred times and not see
it you have really have to have sharp
trained I have been in the field for a
while a lot of people would have walked
over that and thought I was just some
scrap on the surface and wouldn't have
bothered to look
well I can mamak anatomy whoo-hoo can a
tooth I mean I had a study yet RDM stole
clear tan FEMA von Neumann tableau and
can i almond Carbajal rannian will have
to yet
let me akuna minal most arid and the kun
hurry he'll have three to ona I said
well this is going to be something
exciting so I took pictures I took some
measurement and I left the site as it is
and disturbed I put in an email and with
couple of pictures by the locality and
send it to a lab
Greg and I received an email from him
from the field we both open the picture
and we were so excited about what we saw
that we ran into the hallway smack into
each other and said did you see that
that's the most extraordinary thing you
can see the email coming from Phil &
Belling raving Jeff and everybody
involved in this project like wow this
is a primate here it doesn't happen if
the sheriff dr. ellby freed me no hey
hey Alice Toa healthy valhallen well
then we we don't eat so far you three
acetyl and you lose you were terrific
the number cannot be Sur de Xiang una
comas mowett an associate an mineral is
yet quenette illallah mujadid mr.
donalsen jb
mohuru Dalai Lama and jdv mr. baboon al
gelada paddle and canonicus elephant
we're heading for historic el mismo
attend its move Egypt to Pittacus here
you can see primates with the more
recent things at the top earlier ones at
the bar
and a gap early in what we call
cattorini the beginning of apes just in
here this is a big area of uncertainty
in primate evolution when that fossil
came back it was immediately apparent
that it's really good bone really nice
sediment that comes off of the fossil
very easily so basically what the odd
found was a face of a very interesting
primate you can see here there's one
orbit one I hope you will here's about
the other orbit there's the forehead
going up in this direction here's the
nose here there are some front teeth
incisor teeth here if you flip it over
I'll put it back down here you can see a
row of teeth here here's a large canine
and some molar teeth and grinding teeth
back here and then this other little
piece over here actually is the ear
region which preserves some interesting
details as well so here was something
wonderful and you could see that it was
very primitive at the same time and that
was exciting
and then the next key for us was how old
is this what was known until now
old-world monkeys apes are separate by
the early Miocene but how they connect
to Egypt OPA thickest and when they
became separate from Egypt OPA thickest
and new world monkeys has been a big
mystery al-khawaja deed booklet Ali is
in Sudan you see Jason sees cotton
Australia via multiple edges
if we look at the Paleo geography of the
African continent today it's separated
from Arabia by the Red Sea but at the
time we're working in the Oligocene the
two were part of the same geography the
same faunal province well we were harder
and Beth loves Torah and we have another
issue yet in fact Allah and the testicle
the Queen and I haven't even Europe tea
the line ana-lucia and geography
al-khatib they said yeah Allah to God
and maybe garnet feet
human to zero and arabiya well a free
appear other than what I've been working
in fossil beds that are younger than
this since about 1994 very interested in
understanding about early ape evolution
and it's been frustrating in that our
fossil record is basically for Apes you
know goes back to about 21 million years
and there's nothing prior to that part
of what's interesting about this is it
is not a monkey and it is not innate
humans apes and old world monkeys all
share a common ancestor this specimen
would have been very close to when apes
and ogle monkeys would have diverged
from one another very close and time and
we think also in anatomy to the
morphology of the common ancestor
between old-world monkeys and apes first
question I ask people like yet when they
find nice fossils is where is the rest
of it you can see it as a beautiful face
the forehead is here but the rest of the
orbits the eye sockets are missing if we
turn it where is the brain case so
definitely we'll go back and try to find
more and better specimens like this
and how another listen we have a blend
to open quarry and little paraty where
we find this primate we think this
publication is important because it's a
an important missing link I know some
people don't like that term but I do
like it because it fills a gap in time
fills a gap in form and it helps tie
things together that we weren't able to
tie together convincingly before this is
just the beginning